laughs
good morning everybody welcome to this
uh in mechanical city council Workshop
uh looking ahead uh to ltp looking at
City Center vibrancy
um I'm Darren Ludlow and I'll be
cheering this process today we do
actually have apologies from mayor Clark
and uh also Tom I think those are the
only ones I've had but it is a workshop
so we just note that so this Workshop
is uh being live streamed in accordance
with the principles of open and
transparent decision making
so while we accept the councilors will
have their own view on many matters and
many cases might already have views with
uh on what the right answer to an issue
is
you are not required to approach every
decision as though you've given it no
prior thought or have no existing
knowledge or opinion
however you are required to keep an open
mind and you must be prepared to change
or adjust your views if the evidence or
arguments warrant it
that means you need to take care with
that what you do or say doesn't make it
look like you've already made your
decision before you've considered all
the relevant information and evidence
and that might include after the
workshops ended so a reminder to the
public that no decisions are made here
however there might be a preference
arrived at at the end of the workshop
this only became a decision actually
once we get to the council meeting at
the other end of the process an all
relevant decision making information is
presented there in an open forum
um there is no public involvement in
these workshops it's a chance for
counselors in manafina or
representatives to discuss matters
public consultation will follow and that
engagement is always open there's also
the let's talk platform and there's a
link to that in the description beneath
the live stream video so the pricey that
we have a workshop the workshop helps
shape the document that we will put out
for public consultation
then we've received that public
consultation and then in an open manner
we make those decisions considering
everything at an open council meeting
later on
it's the simplest way of explaining it
are there any questions at this point
if not thank you welcome and
um Rhianna and I'll hand over to you
thank you I'm just
accurate counselors I'm just going to
work out how to get the slides moving
foreign
okay so we have
um quite a few topics that you as
counselors and the mayor wanted to
discuss today as we look at the first
topic for the long-term plan
um what further investment if any do you
as councilors want to consider as you
work towards your vision our city with
heart and Nako aroha in the city center
so as officers we've just tried to
divide up the conversation into two
parts for you the first part talking
about place so and the physical
infrastructure of the city center and
then the second topic talking about
people so obviously a lot of investment
has gone into the city center through
the last long term plan
um and so you may well be now wanting to
turn your attention to how do we best
activate and make a success at that City
Center so you can see the topics for
discussion up there on screen
so um yes just to follow on from what
the chair was saying this
excess feeds into a number of different
parts of the long-term plan so from this
conversation today we as officers will
take some direction from you and then
bring more further information forward
to Future workshop on strategic projects
to papers for decision to cancel into
the ltp consultation document itself
so before we kick into the conversation
just a brief reminder on where we're at
in the whole process we've begun the
Strategic decision-making part of the
process you'll recall you agreed all the
workshops you wanted to hold through
this year at the end of last year and
this is the first of those behind the
scenes the staff are working on the
various components that go into the
long-term plan primarily the
infrastructure elements and the budget
elements all coming together to support
those Workshop conversations so we will
be in a position probably to start those
public part of the conversations the
informal pre-engagement around May June
time
so the key question for this Workshop
what should you prioritize in working
towards that vision
and just a reminder that any new
activity not already in the plan will
require additional investment of some
sort of impact rate so just something to
have in the back of your mind through
the conversation
um so I've probably already covered off
this slide just a reminder that one of
your strategic priorities the city
center renewal and the development of
this city center master plan to support
the council's investment as ICL has
really taken place through the last long
term plan and underpins this decision
making
today so the first topic I'm handing
back to you chair Russell is going to
talk about City Center Street stage one
briefly before you guys can talk further
about
um what you want for ESC Strait
welcome Russell welcome John again thank
you very much for for giving up your
time to be a part of this process I know
that it's not an insubstantial amount
that you've given to us so far through
this and we appreciate it you're welcome
have a video
thanks cheer um
I'm talking about history and place and
I guess we've focused a little bit on S
Street but this is really starting to
have that conversation that we've we've
seen his street come to light over the
last couple of years and I think it's a
really good opportunity to say how are
we going to use this and and recognize
what that place forms in our city
um we also need and I've highlighted a
number of areas here that this street
also has access for many other purposes
other than just I guess the people so we
have underground car Parks we also have
need for people to be able to get in and
get dropped off for people who can't
necessarily walk distance so I guess
we've got to keep all those things
in
perspective
there is an opportunity that we've got
some Play Elements already in this
street for the kids to play while
they're there with their families I
think that's a good opportunity to sort
of recognize
and with quite a lot of discussion uh as
in later slides about how we make sure
that vibrancy is retained and used
because history is starting to look
really great but we've actually got to
make sure it keeps delivering the
purpose of
in use in this area just the last piece
is to make sure that it is actually we
continue to understand how these streets
link together and how we don't lose that
I guess that opportunity to make sure
that yes can Dawn
become part of a city heart rather than
just streets that are individual I guess
that's the that's where the linking
happy to ask have any questions on this
street at a high level yeah
thank you um I'm not sure if it's high
level actually
um
some of the Play Elements along East
Street when I've been down there I've
noticed that they could be quite a
serious health and safety risk for
elements of our public such as our blind
people so in that development of that
space was there consideration for this
each each of their stages we've had a
independent audit undertaken by the
Jones Group which is the septid which is
the
um there but we will continue to monitor
monitor those areas so some of the Play
Elements we refer to are in the garden
area so the kids can actually climb on
the blocks rather than necessarily um
stomp on the plants I guess yes yes I
understand that but is there like if
someone's walking there and they're
blind they have no prior warning to an
area of where they would expect stable
grounding so is there like
elements there that could improve there
for them certainly on the North side we
have a tactile band and I guess that's
that's the the effort that's made and
that's been used consistently by
designers elsewhere in the country so
okay yeah thank you good question thanks
Ray
any others at the moment
no thanks Russell
that was easy
it was easy
you brought us back into time
ahead of time rhiannons asked me to not
to be too long so big slide please
so the second part of I guess
um my presentation this morning on on
places about the master planning when we
started the master plan for the city
center some
two and a half years ago or more we
really focused on the sort of the blocks
with DTE Dawn and
Kelvin as as the Hub and what's been I
guess we've started to see is with some
further development and further
investment by other parties and expand
out a little bit so we've been
looking with ismos again how our master
plan could expand out a little bit and
actually what does it tell us and and
how do we deal with it and obviously
with distinction hotels
developing the old
Menzies building in Lower East Street
there are some questions about how you
might access that area
um
what then what their needs are and I
guess that's still evolving so what
we've done is tried to test a little bit
about
how we would get access into lower risks
people because at the moment the only
access is from 11th Street which for a
hotel makes a little bit difficult so I
guess this slide really just starts to
raise some of those questions about
what do we want to do in that area of
their City how does it actually how will
a hotel link and relate back to our city
with heart which is East Street if you
come out the doors how do you how do you
see what does it look like how do you
get vehicles in and out of their area so
I guess this is really the starting
point for us to
um
contemplate what might happen in that
area
um
we just go the next slide I'm going to
take some questions so that so worth
remembering I guess Russell that that is
and always has been Road
success Road Reserve that's correct
we're physically
stop some of it
but it still is really still is right so
really I guess
what that sort of links clearly onto in
the next in the next stage is actually
um what purpose does what replace serve
going forward and and how how might we
use that in conjunction with any other
development to
to actually link
um those areas to this to the city
center and so I guess the options that
have been
um
started to be tested are
what is the purpose of it you know is it
used as a public space does it return to
a street with some form of building on
around by
people or do we actually create as a
bigger development so I guess that's the
sort of the The Wider test of
seeing just beyond our I guess our
initial works and
Eastern Dawn streets that's actually how
does this actually start to grow over
time and how does this actually relate
to the wider City Center
a lot
um it would say that if it was um
foreign
it's also worth bearing in mind that in
some of the public consultation that
we've done in the past that there's been
very clear feedback that a lot of people
don't necessarily feel safe in there
either which is something that council's
trying to deal with Grant
um have we discussed or engaged with the
Developers
particularly in relation to how
transport plays a part of their
development we've started that
conversation I've met with Jeff Thompson
and rock talked and we just still need
to carry on because their their
development's evolving and so will their
plans evolve yeah but I guess the clear
message that we all people walking out
of a hotel are going to want to be able
to see history so what what happens next
I guess is really what this conversation
is so it's the functionality of what we
need to design there or is the first
question the second thing I have around
um the the public space in his you know
historically walked in place has been
there but when you look at where we've
now developed with ICL
and
um
you know in my head I wonder why other
than the people perhaps in the motel why
they're going to head that way
and are they more likely to hit West
I think no North North
um from the end link up Dawn Street in a
pedestrian manner which comes back to a
question around what linkages do we have
between esk and Dawn
are they vehicle and pedestrian or are
they predominantly pedestrian so I'd
like to see some more information about
how a city center can be formulated
around the need
in that mix of pedestrian usage versus
vehicle usage and then also around that
importance to have a public space
somewhere in the mix there and bring all
the way to the Taiwan before we make any
decisions
Evelyn
so as a person who remembers when it
used to be a street and there were
businesses down it
um
may I say that I have two thoughts about
this
we've
we're proposing to change because the
use of a building is changing I'm not
sure that's the best reason to actually
change walkner place because
unless East Street becomes really
pedestrian only
there is not going to be a Safe
Gathering space in our city with heart
it's I mean I I take on board that not
everybody always feels safe and walk in
a place but that that's the same
wherever you go where from time to time
people decide to make a space their
personal place and unsafe for other
people to be in
um and we need to resist that but to
change it because the use of a building
at the lower end of that street is
changing isn't necessarily the best for
all the citizens of the city it might be
best for their business and I think we
probably need to consider whether there
are other things that we can do that
make what in a place a safer
um public gathering space or whether we
are going to have to look at what the
alternative is which to me would be
making Essex Street pedestrian only and
how much appetite there is for that
we're not sure so that's just my initial
thoughts but I'm because I'm a walker
I'm not necessarily hung up on the idea
of where cars can and cannot go
um I had seemed to navigate the city
reasonably well as a person who walks
places and maybe it's just that we need
to actually think about some places are
more for people who walk rather than
cars oh can I just no sorry Erin
sorry I just wanted to add a
clarification just around I guess the
the driver for doing this mini Master
planning Edition
um it's definitely not around simply the
change of the use of the building of of
that use changing it's very much more
around that when we went back to the
original intent for the master planning
work it was around how do we try to
support investment in the city and that
was very much around when Council
decided to put the money in for
obviously the investment of ilt and the
langlands the investment in ICL
um we did look obviously around the
investment that sit were doing
um that's it's been sort of a key
consideration as to whenever there's a
major investment in the inner CBD how
does council look at how we support and
interact with that investment so I guess
I just wanted to take us back to that
original intent of the master plan
and also the fact that to keep in mind
that we it although it's not a permanent
public space in esque street we were
very conscious of trying to develop
quite a large Gathering event space in
the center of esk Street
um and we do have the bollards at the
end there and you know the intention at
least of Staff will obviously take
direction from elected members is that
we would quite frequently look to close
that off and hold events within that
public space as well although I
acknowledge the fact that that doesn't
make it a permanent meeting space
thanks Trish then grown
I like the idea of
drawing people in to the place that
we've developed so we've got we've got
the isk street we've got the um the
building the mall building I like I
would like to think that we could draw
people this way and that way so limited
it's actually attractive it's sort of
like it's a place that perhaps I don't
go but it may be if there was some art
or some kind of visual stuff and it was
a rather than a static space it was a
place that people would be pulled
further into the rest of the
um hair developer
a grant then rare than Leslie yeah and
thanks here and I think that is a really
important principle that we need to
remember that you know we're trying to
encourage and Foster investment in the
city and so we need to take very serious
consideration of that when we so you
know please you've raised that point
um
you know I still think that we've got to
be flexible around you know there are
other options around where we create
public spaces which are more closely
linked to the investment we've made in
Lincoln that isn't just walk into place
so you know I think we've got to really
look to our officers to bring some
options to us and they might be a little
bit bold but I think there are those
options around if we're really trying to
develop up a public space that we can
have
you know events that support the
investment that not only we've made but
also business businesses have made like
ilt and and Thompson groups
yeah
uh thanks Mr chair um we know that
historically this particular era has
always swung around when there's been
mood of councils in public to change
where that all those areas of function
to our city or heart of our city have
been
um so what I'm thinking of is a classic
example of Christchurch and we have an
era of the bridge of remembrance and we
have people that can utilize the area
and have types of different types of
public interactions and events going on
there
um there are other Town areas too where
they have the space difficulty of
deciding what to do with is it
completely accessible by vehicles or not
my preference
um
since being here since I was 13 years
old is to try and keep some of that
uniqueness to what in a place
but modernizer for business potential
growth so that we aren't and are not
cutting off any future businesses that
could be established along that corridor
from the hotel from having for traffic I
do think we do need to be bear in mind
service vehicle needs for surrounding
businesses currently
um and I take on board what Darren said
it is and can at times become a safety
issue
but if we address the existing problems
to make it an attractive area we may
very well see our public actually buying
into this and making sure that our
community is actually safer over all
there so I'm excited to see some Vision
some future visions and how we can link
our hotel into our main area
um
and I you know I just can I just clarify
Ria that whilst that might be your
preference your mind remains open yes
and I guess it was absolutely
excellent thank you for that Leslie
thanks Mr chair um
some of what I was going to say
I'm just interested I suppose from a
practical point of view if we're going
to explore option two any further that
we have quite a bit of information on
what that would mean for the State
Highway flow for instance
what it would mean from the point of
view of
um the length of time to achieve it
because it would include some
um just looking at the arrows it would
include some fairly massive
deconstruction
um possibly including the large
structures in the middle of the state
highway at the current time The Pillars
of Strength yeah
um so I'm quite interested in
for option two to be very much fleshed
out as to the actual reality the
relationship with the state highway
um whether whether it would achieve that
effect and also with option two
um
I would like it fleshed out
for alternative public spaces because
option two would definitely
um
would definitely invite us to have a
very clear
council plan on what was the alternative
Town Square
so Russell Leslie raises a good point
but currently it's a controlled
intersection anyway just not necessarily
for vehicles coming out of esk Street
correct
that's great we we've got a pedestrian
Crossing in that space so and I guess
that's what the previous slide sort of
started to test some of those vehicle
movements and
um
the the slides were really to bring some
options and
I guess create a conversation
John Green might um
well thank you Segway
um good morning everyone and um I'm here
I guess there's a capacity of chair of
the city governance group um I just want
to stress that that group um which was
formed to assist council with the
development of the master plan
um has a no budget and B no
decision-making Authority so it's
advisory or representational only but um
along the way since early 2020 we have
acquired quite a bit of insight and and
IP around this process so hopefully we
we have something to contribute to it
um I think it's probably worth just
recapping a little bit where Aaron was
um
the master plan brief originally of
course was a very tight area and that
was partially in response to the fact
that a proliferation of of projects
around the city meant that we did a lot
of things but didn't do them well and we
were spread too far and that's a
fundamental part of the master plan so
it is a fairly tight area and of course
been exciting to get the first stage
done with this condom pretty near
finished and
um we've been here a number of times
talking about what next so again Keen to
be part of this process but I think one
thing has come clear is it was never
intended at the master plan or the
upgrade of the city hall Rejuvenation of
the city
would live solely within that area and
so it's quite exciting to be starting to
talk about the other side of D in
particular because we've said or long as
we've got good permeability from the
north we have good permeability into the
city center from the East but from the
south it's not so good and from the West
it's difficult with these so we do need
to think about how we bring that into
the conversation so it's good to be
having that conversation
um in respect to
um what in a place
um
I think uh be fair to say our group you
know they all have a range of ideas but
probably if we got up a little bit we
would say we need a meeting place we
need a people place but is that the best
place to have what I might otherwise
call a Town Square
um and I think most people well they
don't want to lose what in a place from
having the meeting capacity that it has
now it's probably not the best location
for a Town Square but I would equally
understand that people didn't want to
give it up
and this they knew what they were going
to get but I think if we were just
putting it out there we would say
ideally Town Square would be even more
centrally located away from that heavier
traffic Route so I know there's some
sites under consideration but of course
you know that's that's tricky at the
stage but I think that's that's part of
the conversation
um the next part in terms of just
looking at these which guys have
developed and again our group hasn't had
a chance to consider these or discuss
them yet but
we have a saying you know when we
understand our options we make our best
decisions and I think that's probably
the next piece of work is we need to
bring some of these now to life and
um them up there and say what does it
really look like take into account the
traffic considerations
um the thing we always forget about
what's under the ground if some of this
work has to be done anyway and some of
these streets have to be worked on
anyway then the question is what are we
going to put back on top of the the work
when it's done so there's a bit of work
around prioritization a bit of work
around what areas need to be disturbed
but um
your you know our perspective I guess as
a group or anything else is
maintain the momentum retain the IP to
the best knowledge we can with
continuity of people and resource
um and let's put what we've already done
to work so let's just not stop it is
condom but let's link them together and
then they'd start thinking about
you know how much more could we do where
is the opportunity and the opportunity
is always about people it's not about
buildings it's about people
thanks John Barry yeah um I respect it
uh there's going to be a lot of money by
uh Mr Thompson with the Menzies building
I'm just a bit concerned about the the
Nook going north from that building all
the derelict buildings that are there is
there any plans for that he has plans
for those yeah they form part of his
development okay I think one point that
was made over here before was
we've said from day one through Master
planning and then into stage one that
Council cannot do all this on its own
and the idea is to do it to the work we
do to a standard that gives the private
investors confidence in the plan and it
becomes a catalyst for um for ongoing
investment from the private sector
um the job is too big for Council alone
yeah
just following on from through each year
what you just see it and what Aaron said
it may well be that East Street becomes
a meeting place closed off for
particular events so that could be even
if it was just temporary you know at
nights and things or weekends that
perhaps it could be a way of pulling the
people in but also having a space for
people to gather possibly yeah I think
the idea would be it's in some form of
town square size appropriate to the for
our population you know where to go to
have your lunch where do you meet the
family yeah where do Young mum stop and
feed their kids lunch because they're in
town shopping I mean that would be the
ideal and needs to have another facing
aspect and needs to be warm
needs to be safe there needs to be a lot
of people around and ideally it has
facings on to retail that is also
activated by the people being there yeah
yeah you can't always get exactly what
you want or the perfect solution but I I
think there are solutions and
opportunities for solutions to that
effect and I think in the main they
would be more biddable as spaces than
the one we've got foreign
thanks
at the end of that piece Russell thank
you next time great thank you Russell
thank you John cheers thank you
which brings us to Urban play
Mr goodbling welcome sir
thank you chair morning councilors good
morning
so
um this possibly touches on a point that
counts the Germany raised a little bit
earlier and the conversation around
it's a that's a package you know it's
not just one solution and and one of the
things that have been talked about some
quite some time is what does destination
play
uh and we've debated that and we've
um
we haven't quite landed on the
possession and so what the team are
working on at the moment and I'm just
going to give you a run through of our
plan and then probably seek some
guidance and feedback from you as to
what are the things that you want to see
when we talk about Urban play
in terms of location in terms of
activity in terms of who we're
attracting who we're not attracting in
terms of safety all of those elements
I'd love to get that feedback from you
after I've given you a bit of a run
through about how we're going to
approach this
so we've got a really good working
partnership with active Southland and so
we've uh talked with Vanessa Huey who's
a new CEO there and she's agreed to
chair a small working group to develop a
scoping document that we can then send
out to the sport Recreation and play
market and the aim of attracting a
consultant that will help us rise a
feasibility report and that will
basically provide us later this year
with a range of options
um
costed you can then make the call on
which balance of capital versus
operating costs you would like to see in
order to create
a sense of vibrancy through play in the
CBD
the purpose of the group
and the purpose of the work will firstly
just to just a starting point to say
What's the value of play and why are we
doing this and from a sense of place and
with the investment that counseling and
a number of commercial Partners have put
into that area is that this is about
attracting people and keeping people in
our city and keeping them engaged not
just purely on retail but providing
another draw to bring people in
because it's an exciting and it's a safe
and it's engaging place to hang out
we want to understand what the value of
play is in that sense both from its own
intrinsic well-being benefits of
physical activity of mental well-being
all of those elements about what
individuals get out of play but also
from a slightly broader economic point
of view is what could the community
around it expect if we get this right
so we want to understand that
secondly we want to look at for us and I
think this is where Council needs this
is where we need to get more clarity is
what are our options to deliver play
do we invest in one massive piece of
infrastructure and hope that that brings
people in or as you've talked about over
the last three or four months the the
idea of digital or nodal play do we
start spreading pockets of play
throughout whether it's a piano or
whether it's a table tennis table or
whether it's swings or
um how does that look what does the mix
look like or do we not invest in any
Capital whatsoever and do we invest in
people and do we ask people to run
events and create events and so there's
a mix of you know one big capital
investment through to an ongoing
operational commitment around salaries
wages and event costs
so that's what one of the real clear is
we've got to get in our head I think
everyone on the same page to understand
what play is and then to understand how
we're going to implement play in the CBD
and why
so
that's about all I want to say and
hopefully my leading questions at the
start of giving you a bit of time to
think what does play look like for you
and what do you want to see and how do
you want us to reflect that in a scoping
document to bring back to you in terms
of advice
thanks take
personally I think it would be
interesting to see some information
around a mix of uh digital because
that's where parts of the world are
moving and it's certainly a way of
trying to engage
with young people who've told us that
that's what they want
but I think also nodal play spaces
um spreading where the activity happens
rather than having something of the
likes of the Margaret mayhe playground
where there is a center where you see
actively if you're seeing more
activities spread out I I think that's
got to create a larger space of vibrancy
not only for what we're developing in
the streetscapes but also as a benefit
for the retail activity that that
surrounds it in attracting people not
just to one space but to to more spaces
so we're not just favoring those who've
centered in one area of say esque Street
for example but but wider than that and
even potentially looking as as we look
to to push out where can you
engage with things in in Dawn Street and
pastry again not all of that needs to be
Hardware because it's it's not cheap and
we've also seen through some of the work
that active Southland and Healthy
Families have done that there are
portable
methods of play there is a play
container that started off
NS Street
um during the first part of the during
the demolition phase
uh which is currently happening at South
alive I think from from memory and it's
it's great for engaging people of of all
ages so that's just just one thing I
think it's worth looking at Grant was
that a yes
you framed it really well Steve I think
because
and I think in my mind we've got a
really great example in a different
context around how the stadium is so
multifunctional and so it's been created
as a sort of a
you know a facility that pretty much
anything can happen World cheering
Champs horse dancing lemon concerts you
name it in so in my mind I think that's
the challenge for us to try and create
something in our city center and pick up
what John said around you know it's a
it's a mix of you can go to have lunch
with family you can have open-eared food
halls you can have fun small pop-up
youth concerts because that's what a
youth have said they want
um you could have parkour competitions
um and you could have the world's sweet
wine competition in the annually so you
know to me in terms of the air function
and Council it's it's following the
model that we've got with the stadium
and in creating an area that can be
transitioned through a number of
functions for our community and the
output
and the benefit to the community I think
in terms of do we operationally fun that
you know their social engagement and the
glue with gluing back our society and
our community I think
is one of the key priorities for us and
so what and I think if we if we create a
facility like that it is so functional
and able to be used in so many different
ways by so many parts of our community I
think we will achieve that you know that
re-knitting of our community which has
been fractured in my view
I actually like the idea
you know support both what you're saying
because they've been create smaller Hub
type spaces that sort of connect like
these Trails there's a challenge there's
you know that movement around the town
I think to me that's how yeah I think
there will be more beneficial than
having a Center Spot
Evelyn Mr chair I
thinking about the difference between
the hardware type thing in the more
spontaneous
um or people activated
things but I'm also really aware that
things like the play pods the
um table tennis table that was outside
auction house
um chess boards those sorts sorts of
things have been
really popular in the past the issue
with them is the person who's
responsible for packing them up at night
to make sure that the pieces don't go
home with other people and we only have
you know 15 of something instead of 16
or whatever
um but I'm a little bit resistant to the
more extreme well what I think is more
extreme of recreating a playground such
as having swings and things like that
because these other health and safety
implications with that
so things that are more easily
transportable that can be in
one street one day in a different suburb
the next day or or something like that
that that
brings people to engage with the spaces
but isn't restricting of other people's
engagement with the spaces which I think
is where I have probably have concerns
with something like swings and and those
sorts of things but I do see I have to
say
um the children really engaging with
these step the wooden pieces of the city
escapes and
um I saw a little boy learned to jump
off
with the help of his of his whanau the
other day and I thought
it was actually quite
interesting seeing how it activated the
whole whanau to be part of that child's
development and growth and that we
provided the opportunity for that to
happen in the middle of our
straight Scouts so I just wanted to
mention that but for me it was what I've
enjoyed is seeing people engage with
things like the table tennis table and I
love the idea of a piano somewhere
thank you Mr chair um Steve you asked
the question of what's the value of play
and for me
it's
it's never
kept in terms of our community and the
needs of our families here
um some of the ideas that you've put
forward and people have discussed around
the table over the last few months have
been really amazing ideas because it
draws our families back into our city
but brings them back into our community
one of the things so is Evelyn touched
on is actually building the confidence
of our youth to do different things and
be interactive in our city one of the
things I've noted that's been quite a
small but interesting solid Trend in
different areas is the orientation play
aspects and it could it's designed to
different age groups we had the Pokemon
one
years ago it was they just grabbed all
sorts of Ages so if we were just oh
really yes
okay
um it's good but something like that
that challenges the individuals and mind
that not only are they seeing things
like
um play of instruments around the city
but they're also in the orienteering
phase discovering new things about our
city on a question that could be a
virtual
um competition so I think that that's
quite a good idea to bring those
elements in
um as we know at least children are
outside playing now in our Parks so we
can kind of encourage that youth to
their parents their grandparents and
bring them into the city a few years ago
there was a light display in different
areas of the city that people just hunt
and their hundreds came out so I think
it's about offering our community the
alternative ability to socialize and to
have social functions of our city in
between our different people Varsity
like we've got we're so much more
diverse than ever before
um and
we've got a really good opportunity to
make things amazing here and I think
that yeah what is the value of play
there is no price on it it's just the
value of your imagination
trash
um she's getting into my head
um I was thinking you know how could we
connect with sit with you to make a
competition perhaps to do some pieces of
art that go around you know this
um I'm thinking in Christchurch there's
this huge elephant beside the piano you
know and lots of people are drawn into
that also we must remember our youth
we've got to think about how they can be
part of this and I look at the Burger
King
um basketball place people are there all
the time
um even in school hours when they should
be at school but you know I think
something that actually the family can
come in and the kids can wander off and
you know I know that that's part of it
but we just need to keep that balance
um Leslie thanks thanks
um
quickly I'm really interested in the
project Advisory Group coming back with
the all ages concept yes I think that is
vitally important then we are providing
for
the young family right through Majors
who want their own stuff and don't
necessarily want to be with the family
at all so I'm I'm really looking at an
all ages
um and all I just encompassing
report coming back because we don't I I
think we would miss their opportunity
if we concentrate on you on one age
group or even on families but miss out
the
teenagers
um
so yeah I'm looking forward to the
further information
Grant yeah and on the back of that also
that crossed over with what's the
um economic value of those just
different participation
groups in this CBD if that makes sense
because we've got to reinforce the fact
that there's economic value and
attracting those people one so I'll be
really Keen to see some information
around you know family and CBD is x
amount of value to retailers versus
youth versus different pieces if we can
get data like that because it reinforces
you know back to that principle about
this has got to have economic benefit to
the city as well as all the other pieces
as well
thanks I will forever remember as a
parent
whenever we would want to come to town
with two toddlers that they would there
were two places that they wanted to go
when we found out that we were leaving
the house
one was a boy good joint
and the other was essentially a
commercial playground
and I tried to think about why why do
they always want to go there actually it
was it was for play it was it was for
activity and all we needed to do was to
give them half an hour of activity and
our time
which brought us an hour and a half to
go and do what we needed to do so there
were benefits to us as a family and
benefits to the businesses from us being
in that space
but I'm also acutely aware of of the
difference between Toddlers and
teenagers
which is massive and frightening and
both ends of the scale to be fair
um and you know we had in the the last
Council of presentation To Us by some
young people who who talked about the
sorts of things that they wanted to see
and essentially it's being being able to
access stuff that is commercial activity
for free which isn't necessarily our bag
but that doesn't mean it's the only
thing that's going to excite them and as
as we know we've got their engagement
going on with youth we've asked them
what vibrancy is and there's a public
workshop being facilitated by Coin South
tomorrow night that's that's going to
explore that further and and I'm
guessing Steve some of the findings from
there will come into effect with what it
is that you're looking for with with
Urban plane yeah
Kanye you just reminded me with my two
th boys the things that they really
enjoyed was assigned to scientific
discovery jokester
things that they actually had used here
can I just add um I don't want to forget
about her hourly
um to our city you know some of them
have got a lonely existence so we need
to be able to do or have some sort of
activity that brings them into our city
center you know we think music and
movements for our little ones but it's
actually just as active for our elderly
they don't get the chance to come in
town that are really isolated at home so
it's about drawing them back out as well
and it's pretty amazing when you don't
know someone in Southend is a really
good and you don't know someone you see
someone out or you want to help them but
it goes back as well to the earlier that
want to say in my day
than my day you know so it's trying to
make sure that we
have that element as well
yeah good point I mean because it's
still their day yeah it is they're still
hearing with us so you're suggesting a
climbing wall
if we're all Steve Austin maybe that
would work
well I actually I've seen people well
about my age of far more able to scale
those things than than I am at this
point
although it does go back to a discussion
that I see taking place in the UK at the
moment where it's winter
and the need for warm safe places for
older people
[Music]
um
and Mr wise and here is he
you know the foyer of the Civic Theater
where there is a piano
and could be a warm safe place when it's
not otherwise out for rent
um
but do we open it up and do we sort of
say this music in the theater in the
theater for you from
10 to toe on a Thursday or something
like that you know we've got to think of
alternative ways of using the spaces we
have and the equipment that we have to
actually and it was that talk about
Nostalgia that reminded me that
um one of the things in a number of the
places that I see it's not just that
there's a cup of tea there or that it's
warm but it's comfortable and it's
welcoming and every time I go into that
foyer
it's that thickness of the carpet and
it's the colors and all that sort of
thing that make you feel warm and
welcome
um how do we utilize places like that
not necessarily that place but places
like that
the other thing that came up yesterday
when I was at something else was about
safe non-alcohol selling places
in the middle of the city for the sort
of the
the lucians shall we say the people that
they don't they're not perhaps old
enough or they're not inclined to go to
alcohol selling places
um
a place to sit and meet somebody that is
not
necessarily so bustly because some of
the places we're talking about like
retail spaces can be quite overwhelming
for people who are neurodiverse or
um
perhaps struggling with
their personal Wellness
um do we offer places like that and is
that something that would add value to
our inner city like Buena
thanks good point uh it's interesting I
think the portion of the Civic Theater
that you were talking about is now known
as the piano lounge and is hosting a
performance of the Neko harp Trio this
weekend
um but much as people have talked about
you know an old stand-up Rinky Dink
piano in a public space that you could
go and play imagine being able to pop in
there and have a tickle on a Steinway it
wouldn't be a bad opportunity and there
are so many
skilled players out there who might
welcome that you know really interesting
point there for Activation utilizing the
relationship with a place next door
where there's
you know performance and
very good thank you Steve so look I I
might summarize what I've heard and it's
been really great feedback and that's
going to help our team pull something
valuable back together for you
three real key strong themes of coming
out of this conversation is you want to
understand clearly the value of a
centralized versus a dispersed play
offering
both from a social and in economic sense
you want to understand and you want to
really see that we're very clear around
the demographic
targets and how we are flexible in the
use and how we attract different parts
of our community at different parts of
the day and also then relate that back
both to the Social and the economic
value of that engagement
and probably the other key one is you're
really looking for some degree of
flexibility and multi-use approach that
it can't just be one thing and one thing
only to one group of people it's got to
be a little bit of everything so that if
the other three key themes and I think
there's a number of you know points that
you've raised that fall under those
if that are three key themes I can then
take that back to the group and we'll
we'll get underway with that work but if
I've missed anything or you disagree
probably Now's the Time to tell me
it's not a forever hold your piece
because obviously this point there's
forms yeah it starts to inform a
document that comes back that goes out
for consultation so
there is a chance to conjugate but well
summarized thank you Steve
thank you
right uh we are skipping over the city
walkway sculpture garden section which
brings us to beautification and Shannon
welcome along thank you very Cotto
um we're going to go through three main
things so we thought it would be helpful
to start with asking you guys what you
think beautification means
um secondly we'll break down some of the
things well a lot of the things that
council is already doing in terms of
beautification of the city and then
lastly we'll discuss other areas that
you guys think that council could
perhaps raise a standard or come to the
table with something new
um so when you guys hear the word
beautification
um somebody brave enough to talk first
what comes to mind diarrhea aesthetic
before
what do you mean by that so it's how the
outside looks
um maintenance structure
color
trash something that makes me stop and
look
space artwork
two different things all together
combinational
yeah
I'm the opposite to Trish I don't think
of things that make me stop and really
take notice
it goes back to what I said a little bit
earlier things that make me feel
comfortable and welcome yeah so it's not
necessarily could be things that are
unfamiliar to me that I might want to
examine but it's that embracing sort of
feeling I feel about beautification
I'm a great fan of public art in in
spaces but also
that the areas are kept tidy yeah which
falls back to us mostly but there can
also be challenges sometimes around
private spaces where there are recessed
areas onto private building owners land
that when the rubbish starts to form
there we don't necessarily that that's
not our area but I don't think we should
ignore it either
anybody else just making it look better
yeah yeah let's be honest beautification
is a lot about the physical appearances
and and when you look up the definition
it's a marriage of what Ria and Evelyn
said that it's about improving the
physical appearance or the visuals of an
area to make it more of an attractive
place to live to work to hang out so
it's all of those things
um Rhiannon sorry could you go to the
next slide
so let's talk about what council's
already doing so
as Darren alluded to maintenance so
rubbish Recycling and street cleaning
happened six days a week that's already
ongoing
you've just heard and you see every day
the redesign of escondon street so
considerable investment has gone into
making that a more pedestrian friendly
beautiful space that activities can
happen in part of that design involved
having flexible spaces so that you could
have concerts the seating doubles as
stages you haven't seen it yet but
there's changeable lighting art pieces
going in
there's annual Heritage funding
available for facades improvements to
Heritage buildings a lot of Studies have
been done that not only does that
benefit obviously the asset owner but
that's the streetscapes are about civic
pride you know that's it's something
that we all you know have a bit of
ownership in and improving those
buildings makes a huge difference as we
know to how we interpret our community
um Parks and Recreation as well as
routing and planning have been working
on a draft strategy for Road Network
beautification so that'll have to do
with things like the center plots on DNT
other green spaces that have to do with
roadways they they want to be clear
right now that you know that will
include goals and principles but there
would still have to be next steps of how
are you actually putting these actually
into place and I'm sure you guys will
see that document soon
roading has released the footpath
management policy and guidelines which
really they're just trying to enable
outdoor dining your business your coffee
shop you're just not quite sure can you
have sandwich boards can you have
seating great we're starting to outline
that and hoping to work with people to
try to figure out what works best for
their business because everybody wants
to go to a street where people are
sitting outside and you hear people
mingling and and that's a big part of
City Life public art as Darren says so
we do have several pieces of public art
there's going to be some that are
returned to the streetscape that were
taken out during construction but also
Council took
part in some Innovative streets programs
where some smaller murals went out
because of that
more recently Council helped support
through the community well-being fund as
well as waiving the resource consent
fees for south sea spray which I think
we can all agree was a pretty huge
success and there are different public
art things going through downtown
seasonal lighting so right now it's
mostly twice a year at Christmas in
matariki but the seasonal lighting goes
up and then as well as Council several
years ago established that City Center
coordinator coordinator role so that's
our general quick list of the things
that council's already doing now and how
we're involved in beautification next
would be your guys's thoughts of
perhaps the direction that you might put
us towards what else could we be doing
can I just kick off by asking that we
look inwardly to what we're doing around
rubbish
because I I do see an esque Street for
example
um
rubbish and recycling bins which is
great on either end but I don't I
haven't I've looked around I've
struggled to try and find one part way
down and if we're going to be
encouraging more people to be activated
in that area rather than giving them the
excuse to just drop something because
they've got to walk more than 50 feet to
a rubbish bin that we look at at those
opportunities to see
um if I can drop off the rubbishop and
recycle
yep I'm happy to make a comment on that
one
um which was we had this debate when we
were doing the city center master plan
and the design work around how much we
needed in terms of um of rubbish bins
um I was possibly pushing for a few more
but we also didn't want to wind up with
rubbish bin city
um in the middle of the street either so
we sort of came to a compromise where we
would
um go with a little bit less is more
approach initially and then we'd monitor
it to see if we'd gotten it right the
initial feedback is we probably haven't
gotten it right in some places we are
having some bins overflowing at certain
times of day so we're just keeping a
close eye on that is around whether we
need to increase our collections or
whether or not we need to have more bins
in that space but definitely something
we're aware of cool that's great thanks
I mean we're keeping an open mind and
we're gathering information so that's
really cool yeah Peter yeah thank you
I'm glad it's been brought up because I
was going to bring it up earlier
but people are actually stuffing rubbish
in the seating area if they're having
their lunch there the food packaging in
there so it's obviously not enough or
they're too far apart I'm just not sure
I'm very pleased that that has been
mentioned
ring uh just apologies uh for language
thanks
correct the beautification program in
particular relation to the um Network
roading Network that that's a whole city
thing right yes yeah that's a city-wide
yeah program sorry I should have yeah as
well as the yeah
yeah so I I when I do have the
opportunity to walk around the city and
it is by our heritage buildings there
are some and I'm I'm pleased to say the
area there that there's improvements for
the um
for that
and even know how to say that word
um because some of them are quite
concerning yeah um and you know yeah
they have got better but they're not
good enough yeah um they're not they
look like they are unsafe and could fall
down
um and there's even some other
um buildings along other areas that you
know you are mindful after such natural
disasters that there are some structural
concerns of the uh reach out past the
footpath
um as well but I'm pleased to say that
that will be improved
um
that sort of here it is funding profile
so there are two roles that we have as
the council one is as a regulator and
when there are issues that are genuinely
of Public Safety in their Ascent is set
for that then we're able to act
um for other stuff which are subjective
about how tidy things look or don't look
um that's what we try to encourage and
the the Heritage funding is one of those
options so if people are tidying up
their building then it's a chance for
them to get subsidized uh paint to to
make that easier Grant yeah just the
other point around how does bluff fit
into this
into the city center beautification well
if particularly around the network and
loading thing
that would be part of the water City
please yeah I would have to defer to
parks for that question of how Bluff
fits into the road Network
beautification strategy
great question cancel it um look it will
be factored in
essentially what we're looking at is
where do we where do we maintain Green
Space in a gray space and for what's
standard and why are we doing it uh and
so the team are looking at all of these
areas at the moment and so I'm expecting
that that will come back with a view of
the entire area including Bluff yeah
okay thank you
Trish
um also some sort of crazy stuff like
you know just just with paint
um you know just on concrete it doesn't
have to be expensive but you know it
could be
um uh something like flocks has put up
and and but it doesn't have to be like
that but it could be just something
where kids can eat with you know um
cartoon oh I don't know you know
something yeah just sort of a bit mad
but doesn't have to be there forever
yeah some Intrigue and Whimsy yeah
yes
[Laughter]
it does
Erin thank you
um sorry Shannon just as part of
beautification I just wanted to possibly
draw out a little bit more the comment
that councilor Cat made around rubbish
in the CBD particularly in the newly
developed areas of escondon
um I guess traditionally we haven't had
I guess a level of service whereby we
would see somebody go through the CBD at
6am in the morning and make sure any of
the rubbish from the night before had
been potentially plucked out of the
gardens potentially on a Monday morning
um that you know the street had been
cleaned of anything that had perhaps
spilled there the night before it is
something that some other CBDs have that
that regular role of people who go
through and look after that City heart I
guess first thing in the morning now
it's obviously something that comes with
a cost but given that the investment
that we've made in the CBD I guess I was
interested in getting some feedback from
elected members as to whether or not
that's something we felt we should be
investing in
I think it's important that we keep it
nice you know to keep it smart and
attractive and stuff so even if it was
just initially to see how it worked I
think it would definitely be a benefit
really I think so I'm having attend a
conference around the country
um one of the worst things as a visitor
to areas is the rubbish and it's quite
off-putting and doesn't really give you
a good lasting memory so I think it's
quite important to keep it clean
it's often see how fulfilling isn't if
people see rubbish around their leg
rubbish around a little bit Yeah so if
we keep it clean you know probably
carriages people will take care and
facilitate that with I've already sort
of noticed it myself wandering around
that you know some mornings as Chinese
containers in the gardens and things
like that which is not really something
that we want in our newly invested in
CBD could you pick them up I did
actually
in the old days you get weak behind the
ears we're doing that before picking it
up
or leaving it Evelyn uh yes
just the thing about the seasonal
lighting it came up briefly earlier this
year about perhaps putting what we call
the Christmas lights up
please don't if you want to put lights
up for matariki they should be not
Christmas
um because it's not what matara here is
about
um it's not Christmas in Winter
um I appreciate the um ambition to get
more value out of the investment and the
lives but if you think that using lights
to commemorate muttery here is a good
idea then might I suggest that you look
at how we can acquire appropriate lights
for that but again I refer to a comment
that the chair made earlier about using
digital display because I think that
offers much more flexibility
um I think so we do have an item didn't
we ran in a little bit further on to
discuss matariki is that right
discussing activation in general yeah
but anything related to the physical
infrastructure is definitely relevant
for discussion now okay
um so then it's worthwhile um I
absolutely agree with you Evelyn if we
want to do something matariki then we
need to frankly understand what we're
doing
um and why we're doing it
um I have it on my radar um councilor
pontwich has given me a very clear steer
um that we need to be thinking about
matariki
um what I'm conscious of is that we
already have a very successful event
that runs in Queens Park and we need to
think about how we complement that
rather than trying to compete with it
um but I definitely think it's
worthwhile doing I was looking at some
stuff that Auckland did with different
colors of display and and how that
represented the various different
elements of matariki actually
researching that I learned quite a bit
um so I guess what I'm again looking for
is some feedback around from Council of
is that something that we would like to
invest in obviously matariki's not far
away we'd need to get on very quickly to
getting some lights specific to the
purpose and getting some research around
um what we can do in that space But it's
you know to Evelyn's point we can
potentially do things that are quite
effective without a lot of cost but it
will be with some cost
yeah thanks chair and look um I guess my
desire for
for lighting is is greater Mata Ricky
was one example but um if if you look at
our
um
as a daylight you've got we have
extremely light Summers but we have
equally we have extremely dark Winters
so we've got the ability to have some
just some subtle white lightning
um colors very difficult to use colors
because it's so easy to get them wrong
please now Queen's Park band Road Tundra
has gone back to White because it used
to look like Disco Duck there for a
while and that wasn't cool so I I think
the investment for that period of time
because people are going to be using
these new city streets for walking
between the new various entertainment
places so it's just it's it's a very
economic way to give it some some Buzz
matariki is a separate thing completely
but we need to just simple white LED
lighting done
Tastefully
right yeah just um two things one I've
had a better feedback around the
Christmas lights up in the winter time
um so maybe that's a July thing not a
June thing but you know I think that
would be a good thing for us to do and I
think kids would love that and they get
to see them because a lot of kids are in
well and truly in bed by the time the
lights are functional in the summertime
second thing around the matariki is that
an opportunity for Partnership if either
we provide the lights we'll put them up
um
real
the chair
um I'm thinking about the impact of the
um we're not it's not a negative either
a positive impact when I'm driving up to
South City and I see the lights up there
and it's really welcoming
um and I kind of think to myself there
are areas that we could as you say low
cost but we have to invest in something
um I think that would be beneficial for
us in terms of matariki you know our
community votes with their feet when
they go there and there's certainly a
lot of people that do go there
um and it is an amazing event I just
want to see it getting better and better
quite right with CR City and the the
colors of the Aurora that are reflected
off the street lights should go for a
cruise down Tay Street and see what's
happening outside the ICL car park at
the moment it's quite spectacular yeah
that's what I was going to say we were
there in the weekend and there were a
number of cars doing a lap looking at
them no it's not an invercargill yeah
it didn't have the right car but
um I do really would love to see
something from matariki Aaron something
that was tasteful that fitted it didn't
have to be a big or I suppose there is
some cost but certainly it is at our
heart of our community
um
Peter yeah I like to think we could
think outside the square and have
something with a bit of movement in it
uh not necessarily necessarily Flags but
something like that I don't say we
should copper copy Wellington with their
their water feature and that but just
just something different
I wouldn't suggest the wind one like
they've gotten a new Plymouth but
on the lightning conductor
uh maybe not I think it was a
presentation to council a couple of
years ago about potential wind
sculptures that came from a group um
you know they're a thing that's worth
considering at some point I guess but
you've got a weigh up the costs versus
how much space they require versus how
much maintenance they're going to need
but they certainly become a great
talking point if they're relevant and
that comes back to the discussion around
um matariki and Evelyn thanks for
raising the point of making sure that
that if there is something done that it
is relevant well I was going to actually
say because the suggestion was about
relationship with Evie and the the thing
about it is whilst we acknowledge it as
a national holiday called matariki we
don't celebrate matariki here because
you can't see much right here at that
time of the year we celebrate poor
worker so we're not going to do things
in conflict with what goes on in Queen's
Park
anyway as you know you have done things
like the muttery breakfast
um Parker breakfast where we talk about
the astronomy and and have breakfast for
people
um Tera aroha did a a different kind of
thing last year we're doing our own
thing which is different but I think use
my point was more about if you're going
to use lighting make it appropriate
lighting not lighting that is about a
Christian Festival
that is held in winter time in the
Northern Hemisphere and I think we need
to be really clear about what we're
doing and why we're doing it and if
we're investing money but for me I
really took on board what the chair had
referred to earlier about the
possibility of other ways and I was
reflecting what you said about the the
lights that were reflected on buildings
during the markets two three years ago
um
it's a relatively easy way of doing
things and for Grant and those who said
about the eating spaces and in the inner
city you know the south side of s Street
could reflect onto the north side of
East Street or the north side of day
stick
um Don Street could reflect on the voice
of music you know it's and provide a
different perspective because of those
facades change even how the images look
because I noticed that they look
different depending on which building
was reflecting it back
it's not permanent infrastructure which
is the issue with the Christmas lights
because they get
um really battered during the the heavy
weather events
um I think that was one of the comments
about
um
they get affected by their winter
weather much more so than they do about
being up in summer that maybe the modern
ones don't as much but it was a comment
some years ago when they did go up in
Winter that they got a bit of a beating
so we need to think about those things
before we make those decisions
bring me right I see I see a couple of
options here is that um Erin if we
engaged uh with um uh professional
lighting consultant yeah just just to
touch on ideas and and and simple quick
fixes to more serious stuff yeah so that
would be the next step after getting
some direction today out of the workshop
that that's something that Council
wanted to pursue
um essentially if I came back and said
you know we're going to need a couple of
hundred thousand dollars to make this
happen
um I wanted to see whether there was
some interest in it first frankly
because
um as much as we talk about doing it
cheap
um the once you have the equipment you
can obviously roll it out year on year
fairly quick fairly cheaply but given we
haven't made that initial investment
we'll have to have a look at what that
cost would be no cool because the other
option is a return trip to China I don't
think I don't think so
we've got some new counselors though
that's not happening there's a reason
I've waited till I really had to to take
this one on counselor
I guess um you know like we're sorry Mr
chair sorry
I guess you know it's it's it is that
time when we put together all that we
wish for
um and all that we want in terms of
having Community
um happily involved and things looking
pretty and beautiful and things like
that and I guess it comes back to the
expenditure of that wish list yeah so um
from my perspective
um and I'm open-minded at all times that
um
I'd want to be responsible spending for
something that would be quite valuable
to our community and not a sent over
so you know it's interesting because I
think everybody's enthusiastic about
lighting but it's a really good
grounding moment when you say that we
are trying to you know yeah so maintain
a cap on on potential rates Rises and go
well yeah this is the process we go out
uh we say well we feel this way how do
you feel and it might come at a cost is
that something that as a city as rape as
you're prepared to invest in possibly a
better sourcing process that may have
been used previously or step aside from
that but that's essentially what one of
the things that that today is about yeah
yeah absolutely
um beautification is important because
it it Fosters pride in our built
environment and there's really been a a
push in the last I'd say five to seven
years to to really move that way when we
did the master planning consultations we
just heard the word pride over and over
and over again
um so
I'm gonna go through what I think I
heard is your guys's main points just so
that we know moving forward what we can
take back to the group so the first
thing that came up was the maintenance
of council assets so we heard about
rubbish something that we didn't touch
on was graffiti for since 2020 there's
been quite a market increase in graffiti
I know that um within the Heritage
portfolio I I have a lot of calls for my
Heritage building owners our
understanding is there used to be uh
some budget to work on that and there is
that no longer so that would be
something I would put to you guys to
consider moving forward as to graffiti
removal the second would be improving
neglected buildings as you said you know
you look at them are they safe they are
improving as Grant said there are a lot
working
towards a better appearance something
that didn't
come out of that conversation but that
maybe you had meant did you also include
the untenanted spaces
like those first stories do you feel
that they affect how you see a building
yes so I look at it building in its
wholeness
um the size not just what's on the
footpath in my height
um so
Verandas make it hard yes well not for
me but maybe for someone else but but it
is it is there
it is
so you try and be serious and these guys
don't do they don't do that but anyway
so so yes I think it's important
um
that we do have unintended spaces also
maintained and I really you know it
comes up a lot of times in discussion I
don't know how we as a council can put
the onus on a non
um it's what I touched on before Council
the stuff that visually
annoys the living dance we can't
actually do anything about it I mean I
saw a reasonable degree of lawn growing
out of the uh Miranda above cotton on
this morning the old Cotton On space
um but that's
we can't go around and touch private
property but we can contact the building
owners and ask them to but if they don't
and we do yes and until it's a health
hazard there's nothing we can do Barry
yeah um it's always concerned me and
Ryan will probably be able to help me
out with this uh the CCTV thing we can
do it all all we want in this city if we
haven't got any security
and people don't feel safe from going
into areas
we need to do we need to work in
progress and it's coming here to Council
next Thursday Thursday Thursday
thanks Thursday
um look just touching on it's it's a
form of graffiti it's
the black tire marks that create these
uh bloody mosaics and stuff in the in
the road you know from burnouts oh
you've already touched on that no no she
did it the other night oh she did it the
other night
[Laughter]
sleep with your eyes open
sorry but I just you know you you look
at it and I don't know whether it upsets
other people but to me it's um it's
tough if it's a state highway
but obviously um with the CCTV number
plane recognition and stuff I think if
we get that far yeah
so just I'll come back to Shannon's
summer anything else that um
um final thing that I think I heard was
we're looking for some Intrigue Whimsy
in color
something that catches your eye but is
also welcoming those things can coexist
the same so maintenance
look at our condition of our buildings
and then bringing some color and
Intrigue into downtown can we just
emphasize the digital aspectively I've
got it noted down
thank you Shannon
so Council as that covers off a lot of
the the things that we're looking at
around place and now we move Rihanna
onto people
foreign
so yeah just as you start a discussion
around what do you want in terms of
activating and creating an active space
for people that's moving beyond the
topics we've already discussed on
infrastructure just a reminder on the
Strategic priorities and Community
outcomes that are really relevant to
this area that you've confirmed for this
ltp so um we talked about meeting the
changing needs of arangatahi as part of
the wider population which is growing
older and more diverse and delivering
City Center renewal and a community
outcome for a vibrant safe City Center
that meets our people's diverse cultural
needs so we're gonna um kick off with a
discussion on vibrancy and what you as
counselors see and mean by that
welcome Richard
s oh there we go tag you're it
um just and you've seen the slide before
but I'll just repeat it because I really
do like this definition
um vibrancy simply put to be vibrant is
to be full of energy enthusiasm activity
and life in other words healthy and
Alive presence and the amount of
vibrancy is a reasonable proxy proxy for
a city's General Health and well-being
now is ever understanding what makes
vibrant places where we can come
together is essential for the future of
our cities it's definition by the
American
um
Planning Association but I do like
because it kind of sums up what we're
trying to achieve
again you've seen this one before
the key elements of a vibrant City Flow
that's about how we move around the city
uh we had to get to where we want to go
to but also in a way that's minimal for
us
we want well-loved places that people
are drawn to but also that they come
back to again and again
cultural amenities that are inclusive
where people go for cultural exchange to
learn about each other which is about
creating a healthy and vibrant Society
but also growing Community connections
so it's not just putting on an event or
a celebration for a particular part of
the community that only that Community
sees it's about welcoming the other
aspects of community to to gain cultural
understanding places and events a high
density of unique businesses and events
that are in that place that change renew
and excite so it's not just the same old
thing every year and the last one is
Vibe the unique character or Spirit of
the place and that's important to be
ours and not other people there's lots
of fantastic examples that we see around
the country and around the world and
I've heard some of them just today as it
came in but it doesn't mean that a
carbon copy of other people's ideas will
work here so we've got to make sure that
we take the best of those things but
also put our own flavor our own
authenticity to it
next slide actually just while you're
while you're on it Richard you missed a
discussion earlier on when we were
talking about the piano Lounge at the
Civic and and how and quite often public
spaces there'll be a stand-up public
piano what is the chance of looking at
the opportunity of having people coming
in to
to to play only we've been doing that
for about 12 months now excellent answer
thank you so probably four or five times
a week there'd be someone in their plane
um we've got a concert pianist who's ex
Korean concert pianist who comes in that
stuns everyone we sometimes have to
close the door which is quite quite
quite large quite powerful beautiful and
we have uh uh a couple that come in and
plays with each other which is a
beautiful side and a third age couple uh
and we've also yeah it's really
heartwarming but you can I can tell from
my DS who's playing and what whether
it's the concert Graham sort of thing or
whether it's the um those old songs that
you've heard your grandmother sing we
also have a number of staff that come
over in their lunch time and play so
there's quite often activity there we've
been challenged by being able to
communicate that to the public and about
some of the things that happen so that's
been because of the covert clinic in but
we will open that up and start to talk
about the spin the living room
um a democratic space available to
everyone
in the sort of the social heart if you
like splint thank you Richard bless you
Mr mcwire you are not going to growl at
me then because of what I said earlier
I missed it
okay so that's all well and good what
we've talked about vibrancy but how do
we actually measure vibrancy so at the
moment
um as part of the Beyond 2025 work uh
there's some surveys going on uh and
some research so I've been researching
tabletop desktop surveys of uh the
policies that we have and the actions
that we're doing and it's looking pretty
good but here's how I'm measuring it
through attraction experience place and
performance now these are all lifted
directly out of the retail strategy and
I think they're really good so I've
applied them to everything the first one
there is attraction that's a pull factor
it's why people come into the city why
people use our services now on the left
hand side it's Continuum do they come
and buy necessity I just need a pair of
socks so that's why I'm coming into town
The Other Extreme is by desire I'm
coming into town years to get my socks
but I just like being in town for some
reason and wondering the next one is
experience the experience when they
arrive in our city is it an expected
Norm I can you know it's got shops it's
got a few cafes and stuff or is it
engaging in Delight have I discovered
new things when I'm in is there a new a
new uh little uh laneway that I haven't
seen before is this something a busker
that just makes me smile on my journey
place doesn't function so the bare
minimum a place does what it says on the
box a car packs a car pack
um a place to buy a can of Coke as a
place to buy a chemical
is it fat does it function or does it
provide Discovery surprise and wow are
there
um pieces of art are there pieces of
play equipment that make you think wow I
now I understand what some traditional
Maori games were about I understand
about balance and how you trained for
Kaya Harbor by
um jumping from
um stump to stump all of those sorts of
stories it enriches you and wow I didn't
know that about where I own where I
lived so that's the great uh end of the
place and the last one is performance it
functions it just does what it needs to
do as opposed to the other end it
exceeds the new user needs you go well
next time if I'm sitting out in Gore and
I'm thinking do I need to go to Dunedin
or do I need to go to invercargill to go
actually they've both got an XYZ the
farmers that I'm going to but man I want
to go to invercargill because every time
it's a fantastic experience and that's
about you've heard Pride today that's
about building Pride it's also about
building livability attractiveness for
not only using the city center but as a
place to live there's a place to invest
it's a place to do business and have
confidence that this is a place where
I'm prepared to have my head office or
my showcase store Etc
so that is the um the four factors that
we're going to be looking at through the
surveys
now the surveys that are going out cover
a whole lot of things how far people
have traveled why they're coming into
town what their viewers of the town now
post a bit of development work do they
feel safe what time of the day are they
coming all of these things will provide
us business Intel and we're doing it in
conjunction with uh retailers in
conjunction with the businesses in town
so as we've got a data set that we can
actually delve into for a whole lot of
different reasons we're also collecting
if boss data so that's a way of looking
at the sales of the city in terms of
that block by block what's happening
what's been purchased and what those
Trends have been over the last three or
four years and that gives us a bit of a
metric to put some science to some of
the things that we think are true and
happening at the moment
so that's our approach four factors but
four discussion points that are really
interesting to take some ideas to and
just say well are we doing something
that if you talk about matariki putting
up lights is is it just going to do the
necessity or is it going to be so
desirable people will seek it out and
come and travel for it all of these
factors can be applied to any of our
decision makers around beautification or
Urban Development
just achievement all I could say as well
just a breath of fresh air where did you
get this man from Wellington
pretty good snatch to be fair Auckland
thank you
and also Marie was my Festival in
Auckland I led matrixville so
um
did you fix that yeah
sorry it's just a question regarding I'm
going to LEAP straight into a question
that I get asked at least twice a day by
by people is about low obviously s
Street and a Redevelopment there a lot
of people actually think it's going to
be no no traffic
then I realized it's going to be slow
one way but obviously
um you'll be you know the ability to
with the consent of the retailers to
block off air Street to
pedestrian only for certain periods so
we had covered this off earlier oh you
did yeah you did so that's great so
that's an Ace in the Hole for us we've
never had it before
so you you've covered that did you come
to a what sort of conclusion there's no
conclusions it's a workshop no no no no
however there was the the gist of uh of
what you're talking about was certainly
being supported
that you know that people like the fact
that that is potentially uh because it
feeds so much into what Richard's
talking about here correct yeah I think
it's a fantastic framework to sort of
give us a great insight into you know
where we're at so well done that's
awesome just one dumb Servo sitting on
my desktop at the moment just just with
the measurement I know having three
teenage daughters often they'll come
into the city in a retail experience but
not necessarily purchase and then go
online so it'd be good to capture that
because it's still economic activity
it's just not in the traditional manner
so I think it's important that any data
reflects reflects that as well just so
that we get a full lens of that economic
activity that's driven out of the CBD
not necessarily directly linked to it
and I think that what you're hitting on
there is a as a trend worldwide yeah
there are more and more places that are
I suspect in the retail world are going
to become showrooms that's right in the
same way that the Apple stores have done
for a number of years and and it's still
an experiential thing I still want to
touch and look and think is medium
really medium or am I giant every time I
order off wish you know so you still
want to be able to see and touch a
product but you might want to go home
and think about it and then try and
search for that product but it links
back to that investment decision that
some businesses might make you know
because our factoring net into their
business models so we'll still get
businesses investing will be it they
might shake their retail experience
differently but it's also an investment
that that retailers need to make in
their staff to make sure that they're
giving their customers the client
experience that makes them want to come
and have an organic a 3D organic
interface rather than an online purchase
we also know that covert one of the
positive things out of covert was our
transition to a digital world to an
online world has ramped up so we are
buying more offline than we than what
was expected to do and we've got a bit
of a catch up into just to reevaluate
what retail means and what city centers
mean and the experience aspect is
fundamental mental I know with the Civic
over there we've been doing a lot of
work on pretty in it up and you might
think well let's just try it an
unnecessary but the reason for to get
someone uh off the couch in a demand
culture nowadays electronic with Netflix
and all this it's got to be the
experience with the service they receive
and the visuals and the whole wrap
around it's not just about that product
that show or that retail purchase it's
everything from the um from the time
they get out of it from time they find a
car park to get into that retail store
what was the experience what sort of
surprise delight and what messages do we
give them or confidence and pride in the
city
right um I think Rhiannon do you want to
take this one
so one of the specific questions that we
just wanted to see what you as
counselors were thinking about in terms
of the city center relates to food
trucks it's quite a specific item but
prior to covid prior to all the work
commencing there was some food truck
presence within the city center there
are some limitations on food truck
activity within the environmental health
by law and so just really be interesting
to see what you think about your vision
for the city center going forward and
vibrancy and what if any role you see
food trucks playing in the future
personally I think that there's a an
opportunity that exists as a
semi-permanent one rather that they are
there for events uh to add to but
they're not rate paying businesses who
should actually be our priority
um you know if if we've closed off esk
Street to have an event the ability to
bring in those those food trucks just
fine provided they've got the
appropriate licensing
um but whether they were there unless
they had a permanent August license and
and and I can think of of one that's
that's been in three locations currently
and it it doesn't really compete against
anything else that's that's there
but if you're looking at esk Street
would you have
Hawkers there every day when you've got
rate paying businesses on either side of
personally I'm a little reluctant
towards that right yeah same here chair
look I I do everything cautiously with
with close consultation with the
existing retailers who
can provide takeaway food for people to
walk out of the mall and sit and sit in
this street I mean it's the same thing
you know buying it from a truck or and
you did right their rate paying and
they're paying extremely high square
meter rates inside there so I'm very
cautious but if it all depends on what
these retailers feel as long as the
consultation's right I mean there is a
place for them but it just needs to be
handled extremely carefully I
it's ringing we'll be going rear very
Trish then Evelyn thank you Mr chair I'm
I'm in the the Mind where you're coming
from actually is we need to make sure
that we don't do the Superstar rate pads
that are offering Food Services however
in the same sense um I've also found
myself walking down to Garden Street and
enjoying uncles Kai and others as well I
think there is a place for our food
trucks that just is where they're
situated that is a key element to
getting this correct we know that we've
got alternative services to get food to
our homes and what have you and it is
and it wasn't a vision tree announced a
complete a must so
um yes I'm I do support having food
trucks but in a specific area outside of
the city center
very yeah I think the the place for food
trucks is Reserves reserves and like
territory and places like that but
certainly not in the middle of the city
center
which we're trying to make really nice
I don't think the place would be
anywhere in that area because we're
getting tape
um the revenue from
businesses are actually trying to get
ahead
Trish
balance really I think I'm worth three
and
three and kids love them um and it
brings the kids in we don't necessarily
want them in the city central though I
think they need to be accessible in
walking distance if that's what they
want but not at the expense of the
people who are in the city center Evelyn
it's really interesting because there's
a couple of those food trucks that are
still operating that absolutely
sustained people during
the works and streetscapes and when we
talk about rate paying businesses those
people in their own right are rate
payers they're citizens of this city we
we need to look at all the citizens of
the city equally not just the ones that
occupy Prime retail sites because some
of those aren't citizens of the city
leaving that aside food trucks provide
variety and they provide flexibility
I think that we need we had them before
streetscapes because there was always a
couple of them of recent of recent years
the last eight or nine years certainly
that at least a couple of days a week
operated out of what in a place
so they obviously served a need that
existed prior to the Redevelopment of
the inner city
I
I'm uncomfortable with us saying to them
oh well we've done all this work now you
can go you were necessary but now we
don't want you
can we look at how we can more flexibly
look at this and say to them where do
you see the opportunities
what because it's not just us
I don't know how many people
use
um
the ones that are currently now on
lower part of Tay Street
exactly Third location in the
Redevelopment
um I don't think it's just workers
and so there are places in this even in
the inner city that don't have as many
eight places as we think they do
perhaps these food tracks actually
provide a service and we should think
about that
um
yeah yeah it is a balancing act council
did through a previous coordinator
organized food truck Fridays and walk in
a place which was fine you know it was a
once a week for for two and a half hours
thing but it was also immediately
outside three food retailers yeah
they didn't object because it was an
everyday thing and actually it attracted
people to the area as well so yeah the
swings of roundabouts Richard just if I
could offer a commercial lens to this
we've been doing a bit of research we've
got the um Highlanders coming up for
rugby park uh in March and we just want
to tidy up our food trucks that we have
there so we've done a bit of research
about what different people are doing
around the country in terms of how
they're charging for food trucks
generally if it's a site they're paying
a fee almost like an event fee or a
permit fee if it's a closed gated thing
like we will have at rugby park or a
Food and Wine Festival it's a fee and
then a percentage of take now that's
difficult to maintain and a whole lot of
issues but the point is they've tried to
balance that cost between those paying
rent and those in a food truck there
could be a way where but in contrast to
that if I wanted something in the Civic
for a weekend event I would be begging
them to come along and not expecting
them to pay but may maybe there is a way
in which that if they're downtown if
they're an esque Street downtown that
they do pay a fee and the fee is
commensurate with the opportunity and
potentially that fee could go back into
a vibrancy program and an activation
program ring fenced therefore providing
benefit for the permanent
retailers and the activation of their
space out front again it needs to be
carefully managed you know with times
and so as it's not anti-competitive but
I think there is something that could be
explored there and has worked elsewhere
just recognizing that the footpath
policy is up there as well but I'll just
remind councilors that we do have
something out for consultation at the
moment
any other points anybody wish to make at
this point
right Rihanna
um so you've received the summary of
what the young people told to cancel in
November at Black Friday but this is
just a wee reminder of the things that
were really important to them
um and as Darren as you've mentioned
earlier we're holding an event in
partnership with coin over at sit
tomorrow night and think outside the
pizza box which will look at the four
biggest themes that young people raised
and they'll get to go through a design
thinking process and those ideas some of
them might be relevant for Council to
consider many will be relevant for
private entrepreneurs to look at and
we're really grateful to all of the
stakeholders that are sending experts
along to help the young people in that
process tomorrow night so the things
that they said that were the most
important to them were youth activities
and meeting spaces and as part of that
events were really popular and some of
you raised those kind of pop-up events
that were mentioned as well
um nightlife was raised by a lot of
people
wanting more variety of experiences and
as part of that some more food options
as well
um
then the third area that was discussed
was the city environment itself now lots
of investment has got in both from
Council directly but also through the
amazing murals that have come through
recently and created lots of energy and
excitement in the city so some of the
things raised were actually things that
have been addressed which is good and
then the last one that was came out
through a lot of people was transport so
um just given the focus for what's
needed by young people is an opportunity
to remind you guys of what they told us
can someone tell me young people what
what age group are we actually covering
here because I noticed you talk about
bar you know drinking something
obviously so the consultation that we've
been doing was with people under the age
of 30. and a 30. yeah okay right right
just just looking at the nightlife there
it's interesting you say types of bar
well the trusted open obviously 360 and
probably everyone's been there now
that's that is actually an R20
yeah so that's quite interesting it's uh
it's a limit to to to actually not have
that that particular younger group going
there is a consideration
that people talk to the trust about an
opposite sort of tact where
you sorry you're over 30. you're not
coming in you're too old it's not
uncommon they're uh you know I mean it's
it's worth don't I mean I get a fossil
like me you know you just don't well
that's what the Museum's about you don't
want someone Museum
who wants Petula Clark playing on this
on the on the CD you'd be surprised the
number of young people yeah yeah yeah
but I just like is that is that where
we're heading is that so that's a
commercial thing really it's up for the
market to decide if if you're generating
a lot of Intown night activity
um and you're targeting let's say a
young audience with a nightclub at which
point the general manager the chief
executive of the licensing trust said
they'll lend any amount of support to
somebody who wants to do that as opposed
to a place that was targeting an older
demograph that just creates different
varieties yeah you know not not
everybody wants to go to macca's for a
boy get some people might like a chicken
nugget or what have you it's it's about
the market offering that that variety
a grant then rent yeah and I think for
young people you know I don't think it
has to be every weekend it's from time
to time if they've got events to look
forward to like stand-up week concerts
and those sorts of things that's what
they see as vibrancy because they've got
busy lives and they're spinning around a
lot of other things so you know other
unlike yourself is probably all every
weekend type of man yeah I think the
kids are sort of more looking for a sort
of a from time to time than something to
look forward to so
um thank you Mr cheers um in terms of
like engaging with the youth and when
we're down at the mall
um definitely a lot of the suggestions
have come through uh aligning with what
council members have said as well over
the last three or four months the um on
the previous slide talked about
um
um types of bars you know some of these
kids actually talked about milkshake
bars not just alcohol baths they wanted
to have that variety
um and because you know we've got tanks
so that's that's there but
generally what they wanted to do was
they wanted to feel a part of our
community and have leadership and trust
and salt in them so I guess that's about
making sure that these events that we
are planning
um whatever is finally decided on
actually hits that Target Market of 18
to 30.
um the mini golf was mentioned quite a
bit that
um it was a real shame that
um you know if that we had a limited
designed
um course and they'd like to see
um more of that and the ice skating and
skating it's
it's been one of those things that
is missing people do want to interact
there and do those activities again it
becomes a balancing act we have the
temporary ice skating rink which was was
successful and provided a nice bit of
variety and interestingly was also
supported by uh the gore ice skating
rink and we would want to be very
cautious that we didn't go and establish
a facility that replicates so there is a
balance that's also needed and all that
wishlist too because that comes of cost
as well Peyton
yeah we mustn't forget the elderly of
course I could probably turn the clock
back and uh the old Northern Tavern had
the Granny's bar and that was very very
popular
sea Council apartment John did was that
but you know we must have cater for them
at all ages
happened
bring back memories
in all seriousness yep
and you know one of the interesting
things Peter Rose is a good point one of
the interesting things about making sure
that you cater for the elderly not just
an events but an accessibility as it
meets both ends of the spectrum age-wise
so if you're creating accessibility into
these public spaces for somebody who
might be in a Mobility Scooter or have
some form of disability or just you know
be be Aging in your hips hurt it's the
same for somebody who's pushing a pram
yes yes
if we're putting an age bracket on you
know I probably see it as 13 to 18 and
that that youth youth Market because you
know we have a lot of
um
young young people leave the city to go
away to University and that's I think we
have a lot to stay as well
but my sense is probably that dedicated
for the next 13 to 18 age bracket in
terms of some of these activities we're
talking around talking about around NS
City Center would be more sense but I'd
be interested in some information it'll
be interesting to see the information
because they can be challenging to
please
yes
but it'd be good to see some feedback
great let's dive into that I think the
our role is to engage with the community
and and bring that information back and
sometimes we are the wrong people to do
yeah the actual activity but at least we
can provide that to our partners and the
other thing to be cautious when we go
and talk to community is we have we
often just ask people what they want and
that's not necessarily helpful sometimes
because they will say laser tag and you
go oh should we invest in laser tape
possibly not but behind it what is why
did they say laser tag so doing that
analysis about actually they want
something to occupy themselves it might
not actually be a bar it could be you
know a movie theater that actually has
space to loiter
um so we're we're quite good at creating
spaces to avoid loitering but actually a
lot of us just like to hang out if you
want people to stay in the city they've
got to be comfortable and be able to sit
down and I think there's some great
stuff down East Street that I think I'll
see and be seen absolutely so so I think
I think is the old term yeah so as long
as we we listen to them but we think
what is it what is behind that in terms
of that director and that's the valuable
Point yeah
so that leads on really nicely as if we
planned it Richard so thank you on to
this last slide for the discussion slide
for this Workshop which is just
summarizing and talking about the
various roles that Council plays already
in vibrancy so that we can finish this
Workshop just covering any last topics
that you might want to raise
um so for example in the youth event
that we were just talking about the
reason that we've partnered with coin on
that event who um our specialists in
helping new businesses start and grow is
the exactly because we recognize that a
lot of the work that U.S Council have
invested in is to enable others to
activate the city center not necessarily
to deliver those Services itself so a
brief summary of some of the areas where
you as a council are supporting
activation
Council funds investment in events and
activities in the city center through
both our community wellbeing fund and
the creative communities fund that we
administer so some high-level analysis
just gives you a picture of the number
of activities from those funds over the
last two years that took place in the
city center we have the city center
coordinator role that's based at Great
South and funded by a Target rate on
City Center property that focuses on
activation and connection between
businesses and councils
um
Council owns and operates venues
adjacent to the city center including
these the theater and the Scottish Hall
which we talked about the role of the
piano Lounge we fund Great South which
we've asked them over the last few years
to have a priority focus on supporting
Council in the investment of this made
in order to activate the city center we
work with a range of key stakeholders
including through the city center
promotions Group which John Green is the
lead plays a leading role in
and we produce strategies in order to
make it easier for others to align and
activate
those are always developed through a
great deal of consultation and
engagement Rich has talked about the
retail strategy which has been a really
important document
um I think Beyond 2025 workers doing a
lot at the moment looking at that open
Rejuvenation space and we do have the
regional events and arts and culture
strategy
so
um there are lots of pieces to this
puzzle
um and now as we look at the long-term
planners there anything really I guess
sending back to you chair where you feel
that in order to support people
there's anything else you want to
consider that council could do
um it's not about adding I don't think
it's about adding more it's about
actually quantifying what we're actually
doing and seeing the results so you've
said great South have been doing
um the city center thing for three years
is that right Ren three years or so
about that about that yeah three years
so if we measure that are we able to
measure it obviously it's difficult with
the rebuild of city block
uh it's a subject that's coming up for
discussion later yeah
right but obviously okay moving on from
Great South it's about measuring what
what we do and not just keep doing the
same thing over and over again and that
and that's really interesting with and
tying in with what Richard was was
talking about in his presentation and
trying to gather some of that that data
to make sure that we are on track or
what what the gaps are so I'm really
encouraged to see that's going on Grant
yeah and I think that's a really good
point you've raised ringing around you
know we need to take an investment
approach to this we need to not
um can we see what we're getting at we
need to determine what we want out of it
and see the investment we're making and
then measure that output because you
know that's the discipline that'll get
us the best outcomes or allow us to fail
early around hey that didn't work and
there's nothing wrong with that as long
as I realized that early and then direct
it to somewhere where we are more can be
more successful so we've got to take an
investment approach as opposed to just a
helicopter drop money and hope
everything goes
that's a really valuable Point Grant
thanks for raising it's just you know
Investments sometimes are about having a
go at something sometimes they don't
come off but it's as long as you
understand why they didn't you know and
learn from it that's good Leslie
I suppose just one thing to add
consideration about how much we've
activated the Scottish wall and how much
we can activate it further we've talked
about the Civic the Scottish hall now
has the added benefit of being right
over the road from the sit development
with a lot of a lot more
young people and people with artistic
fear and so forth right over the road so
is it time to have a conversation about
Scottish theater Scottish Hall
activation further activation again
Korea and in support of Leslie
absolutely
um
as I'm sitting here it's occurring to me
that
um we don't see a lot of squash Heritage
apart from a well-known one here in our
city we have the invercargill pipe beam
which is famous yet we don't um hear
about them until their annual
competitions or if we're lucky enough we
can hear them as we're driving down
Queen's drive it's beautiful with
bagpipes so it's how can we have our
Scottish ancestry more involved in our
look and feel and vibrancy to our city
as well would it be really good
um I do remind you of our street name
yes yes is that enough is it enough is
that where we start I don't I don't want
it to there's only one of many cultures
yeah very much so
um I just I'm sorry being on that slide
out there
um with the and I realize we're probably
going to talk about this later actually
um so as our city activator located at
Great South yes has been
yeah okay
look Maria's mentioned something about
the Scottish thing and that is strong
women because street names without a
doubt I mean you could
Robbie Burns that you could do a
haggis haggis is fantastic and I mean
the whole city could be eating haggets
am I
played a little bit of damage on our
Wastewater system but
no we I mean that's something you know
the whole festival I mean we've had the
odd haggis ceremony at home and we've
had to we couldn't afford the real pipes
we had to put on a cassette and uh oh
how retro yeah yeah yeah and but it's
it's great and and those embracing those
cultures I think if we and then you pick
another one you pick at maybe an Indian
one you pick another day that's
important I think I mean I don't want to
be corny but those it's it's quite fun
that's quite fun and if you wanted this
up it's a case of measuring out what's
going on so there's The Tartan Festival
that happens put a skirt on at Easter so
you don't you wouldn't want to clash
with that we have a tremendous
celebration at uh at the stadium for the
valley what are the other opportunities
have a chance for us to Showcase and for
people who've who've um made the
decision to relocate here from whatever
part of the world isolate from from
their whanau it's uh it's a very
empowering thing for you for us to be
able to recognize uh the the culture and
diversity and add to ours with intuition
so do we do we have connections with red
cross that are placing our
um that can actually move along that we
can actually be involved in once they're
ready not telling them but asking about
how we can help support them yeah not
just Red Cross but I mean in a more
Multicultural sense as well
Multicultural Southland Trish then Barry
Multicultural use um Henson Hall it's
set a lot for a lot of their events but
you know we've got a new community
intern um the Democratic Republic of
Congo and we're going to have probably
40 families by the end of the year I
mean it would be an opportunity to help
support the impacts even get involved I
know when the Colombian Community came
in it was only when they got you know
sort of a measure of people and then
they began to form their own groups but
certainly there's a diverse Community
here Mary yeah
um I'm a member of the working men's
club and every year we have the wamatoku
band that the working men's club it's
probably one of the biggest events that
the working men's club here they have a
hagas and everything and the place is
choker
I just can't get anyone else on there so
I think that'd be ideal over in the
Scottish Hall if we could that's which
is much smaller bring that yeah yeah
bring something like that in there Peter
yeah thank you I'll turn the clock back
way back to the early 1950s when we had
all those Dutch people come here
you know what did happen they did some
of them bought a barrel organ with them
and that was a major draw card
absolutely brilliant that would bring
people from miles around
it wasn't Bluff one part of it didn't
even know it was still housed down there
I don't know if we could Source out that
would be something special
how many people here have heard that
music from a Dutch Barrel organ
three of us that's a big thing huge
it's that comes back to something that
Richard mentioned earlier as well is
about finding those propositions that
are that are going to get people out of
their home if I go back to the 90s and
we looked at Live Theater and and what
it was that that saw audiences change
you know there used to be two plays that
Repertory did in the musical theater
major production and a theater
restaurant that they did but actually
since then Sky Television had come along
in the end of five Cinema movie complex
had come along and it was and now we've
got streaming services with with on
demand and trying to get people out of
their home in the first instance is the
challenge but the one thing that
streaming can't
um can't replace is that human interface
you know even though retail faces
challenges the one thing that cannot be
replaced online as hospitality
and and finding those opportunities to
create that that vibrancy is is
something that's going to be the
challenge that we face in the modern
world
they just want to add to that
we used to talk about multiculturalism a
lot
um and the trend is going away from
multiculturalism and into something
called interculturalism
uh interculturalism as a central
government
um thing at the moment realizing and
recognizing that when people come to New
Zealand from their culture as refugees
or as whatever decision they made
they're coming for a reason that is very
important to them and they're very happy
to have escaped whatever the second
generation
uh experience and these people do
experience racism and difficulties and
integration the second generation come
along their children come along they are
really vulnerable because they
experience the racism but they don't
have that negative experience that
they've escaped from and they are some
of them as vulnerable people and that's
where um uh radicalism happens uh
terrorists and delinquency all of those
things happen in a second generation
okay with multiculturalism the approach
was always to let service the Republic
of Congo
and if to give you an Insight across the
road Scottish Hall we host the
Multicultural Council but we also have
ethnic days for all sorts of cultures
over there but they're a bit invisible
because it's servicing an individual
culture and we're servicing so it
actually stays within that little circle
of group The really powerful thing is
interculturalism we bring that group
together with another group and you
expose all of us to it and we go wow
that's the same uh and the Auckland
experience in matariki one of the most
powerful things was the breaking inbreed
concept coming together for a face and
sharing your culture because matariki
has for example a lot of the values that
are Universal about coming together
recognizing passing of people harvest
all of that sort of stuff so having
different cultures come together is the
most powerful thing so my challenge to
to you as you go forward is not just
think about servicing the individual
communities but showcasing them to the
other communities and strength and
solidarity and weaving those things
together you'll get a much stronger
Society plus also it will look more
visually interesting and all those sorts
of stuff
I'm thinking because
because of the Dutch Club experience and
it's exactly what we talked about at the
time they wanted a place to congregate
together but when the third generation
came along
the
the need for it was not so strong
a lot of the families felt more
connected
to
the place that they lived and no longer
were heartening back to the place if
they wanted to experience
where the appearance or grandparents
came from they went back to Holland
um part of that probably was an economic
thing too that it was more affordable it
was easier to fly home it was easier to
go and visit but
we we shouldn't be creating buildings
for or necessarily
um focusing so much on what we think
people want is responding to what they
ask for
um and say well this is the spaces these
are the spaces that we have
rather than creating spaces specifically
because what we've seen over the years
is when the needs go we're left with
buildings that are not necessarily
sociable for other people to
occupy and so I mean I think of
um all the Masonic lodges for example
and we left I think one or two
a invercargill
um but when I was a child I think there
were about six or seven
um you know people's
people's interests change so it's a bit
along the conversation about bars and
nightclubs and things a lot of those are
about entrepreneurial opportunities not
for us to provide
um do our bylaws
enable
um is more a thing but I think
uh Richard's question about or the
discussion about interculturalism and
the use of the spaces that we have
perhaps that's not as visible to the
public as it could be and how do we do
that without this
sorry it's a compulsory gen in the
clubhouse because that would be
difficult
I don't know why I had an alarm for that
but I did thank you sorry
um so how do we actually
encourage better use of the spaces and
places we have in this conversation
rather than invent new ones or
um are we looking for a um
are we looking for an answer and we
don't even have really have the question
yet
I don't know it's it's been a good
discussion though
one of the things that Council looked at
in a couple of its previous iterations
we had a lot of focus on events and
supporting events and the theory behind
that is if we supported
um events of various scales but the
larger the better the the economic
impact for the town was significant
Evelyn Richard raised a really good
point that there's actually stuff that
we can generate within our community
that gets people out and and circulating
as well which is not just an economic
benefit but there's actually more a
social well-being
um which
bearing in mind will have kind of
devolved to over the past 12 months when
when people have become
well frankly less tolerant
um but the timing for that's really good
for us to be to be looking at and again
going out and getting the feedback and
finding out is this a space that people
want to see Council involved in more or
not
I suppose you look at the farmer's
market and how that's grown over time
and how that support lots of like groups
together
um
and I'm just thinking you know with you
even in the sense of you know how
how we sort of fall like
showcases other cultures that you were
you know that we have in our community
and some of that food is always from the
Multicultural food festival there's
different ethnicities grew uh the market
for for their foods and people became
more culinary
culinarily adventurous
um
I think I might have just made up an
England word but it sounds good uh it's
got people out and about and again it
created from something that started at
boys high here's a sense of community
with people going out on a Sunday to to
meet around these these groups and you
know we've got two markets with people
Gathering
um that's a good thing and perhaps a
night market you can combine the two and
still have a nighttime economy that's
not alcohol based and easier to have in
winter but it's more obviously night or
in summer it's there we wish it was
night
oh yeah look at us it's not night
random just wanted to mention that um
this Workshop obviously is focused on
the city center but the next Workshop
that you guys have put on your priority
list is about a broader discussion of
community well-being so I think a lot of
these themes will kind of continue and
come through into that discussion as
well
so I think that's the end of our topics
for the public Workshop right so at this
point just by way of of summary for
those who've been uh joining us on the
live stream
um a workshop is not a place where we
make decisions you've you've heard and
seen the counselors asking questions uh
raising points for discussion and
consideration all this informs the
documents that the staff will create to
bring to us to approve to go out for
consultation and that is for members of
the public where we really want to hear
what your opinions are on those things
it is a vital part of our
decision-making process once we've been
out and consulted then we mean then we
decide that is an open council meeting
so this this has been a new experience
for us having having a workshop in a
public Arena and thank you for joining
us for that